Like most Olympic athletes, I began sports at an early age.
Ten years ago when Pyeongchang begin its dream to host the Winter games,...
...I was a young girl beginning my own Olympic dream in an ice rink in Seoul.
Figure skating can be a lonely sport with hours and hours of practice...
...without a teammate to push you, to cheer for you when you succeed...
...or pick you up when you fall.
But my dream of an Olympic gold medal kept me going.
Our government began an ongoing program called "Drive the Dream"...
...to promote winter sports...
...and to improve the performance of young winter sport athletes.
I was one of those athletes.
Through the efforts of this program, Korea won 14 medals in Vancouver...
...including mine.
So you see, in a very real way, without the continued effort of our past two bids,...
...I may not  have had an opportunity to be an Olympic champion.